you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 News Now
yes your most accurate weather now
forecast how windy is it just check out
the flag this is from our camera at
Sunset Station right across the street
obviously wind not a factor today
obviously we had a lot of wind remember
we had the rain over the weekend none of
that going on right now all watches and
warnings have expired but man what a
mess going on for your family and
friends in other parts of the country
let's see what we got going on out there
we're going for a high of 52 today we
managed to make it to 51 yesterday the
official low this morning at 36 although
some neighborhoods are getting closer to
the freezing Mark we're going to talk
about the three p's here in just a
second so if we make that 52 that'll be
five degrees below the normal high for
this time of year and the low this
morning not too far away from the normal
low record high just a few years ago we
got up to 71 on the record low 19
degrees so let's talk about what to do
if you're afraid of freezing conditions
we still by calling it the three p's
with your pets if you don't think they
can handle the freeze bring them indoors
if you think your pipes might freeze
wrap them or let them drip a little bit
and for plants if you think they can
survive you want to cover them up with a
cloth a lot of folks talk about two
other peas that's people make sure you
check on family and friends and
relatives and also your swimming pools
maybe they might need a little bit of a
covering okay so we got rid of the
system there were some lingering snow
showers over Northern Nevada northern
Utah but the bulk of the storm now over
Northeastern Colorado and as Sherry was
talking about this morning when you mix
the warmer moisture air from the Gulf
and it combines with that big time cold
air there were tornadoes in the Dallas
Fort Worth area as we mentioned here on
the newscast it is Big Time showers
pushing to the east but that snow is
also pushing to the East and it's going
to be a real mess let's get your most
accurate eight day forecast going here
we're talking about temperatures not
changing a whole lot we're going to be
staying up around 50 for afternoon high
temperatures overnight lows going to be
close to the freezing Mark and happy
Hanukkah beginning Sundown Sunday